but the thing I've learned about
lucasfilm and it's true today as it was
back in the independent when I was in
independent Studio days they're very
loyalty based they're so they don't pay
a lot but they bring you back God
they're like if you ever ask them for a
favor they're just like what can we do
you know oh can I you know can I do some
stuff for my album at Skywalker Ranch
like yeah we'll set it up are you
serious crazy stuff they they treat me
so well and my managers have now
realized that like guys it is you
realize if lucasfilm asks us for
anything just say yes because they're
sweethearts then they and they and they
unlike other people where they say oh be
a great favor if you did this they don't
remember favors in this business they
don't care they're trying to get you to
do something lucasfilm actually if they
say could you do us a favor they
remember that you did that for them
right so so yes no one got
animated series as you know people get
paid scale right but Lucas home does
this wonderful thing where they're like
oh you know Darth Maul is uh in this
Brisk iced tea commercial I'm like oh
what cool do you think that they're like
oh no no don't worry the license
basically says they have to use who we
say they use and they're using you so
have fun making a bunch of money on that
you know I mean they're so there you go
make another 10 20 grand
to that commercial was more than that my
friend that was it probably the most
money I'd ever made for the time that I
put in it was like no time at all and it
was insane so lucasfilm takes care of
people they actually take care of me
they're awesome man and I'll tell you
free I'd be a stormtrooper you know
what's funny is I've I've asked I
remember asking a lucasfone producer I'm
like why have you guys hired me every
year for 15 years I mean I've been
underfooted because you're good
constantly well they were sweet and said
that but they said I'm like I'm con
they're like because you stay out of our
way Sam I'm like what do you mean I'm
like I'm constantly bugging you guys
well what's going on with this what's
going on with that who's so-and-so and
he's like yeah you're always asking
about plot points you're never asking
for a job you're always asking what's
happening with you know the mandalorians
what's R2D2 thinking at this point you
know what I mean like they're like your
questions are always nerd based but you
never ever ask us for a job you stay out
of our way so they're like be easy to
work with yeah they they have a very
chill mentality over there
where someone who's pumping himself up
and trying to look what you're talking
about I'm so important they don't like
that no they actually like it it's like
who does what did George Lucas do he's
like you know
he's going in for a rehearsal there no
no like a he's reading people for Han
Solo and uh he's uh going in and oh
Harrison what are you doing here oh hey
George I'm just trying to build a
trellis here for
uh you know the studio Ah that's great
anyway good to see you Harrison it was
great to see you uh hey you know
Harrison's working on your uh travel
yeah yeah he is he was great in American
Graffiti uh we need a reader for these
and we're short one hand solo uh let's
just have Harrison do you think hey
Harrison you know George do you want to
read uh uh can you do the reader for
this uh yeah [__] it okay
and then he's Han Solo you sound exactly
like Harrison Ford no one does Harrison
there's there's okay there's there's
young Harrison Ford Han Solo I'm captain
of the Millennium Falcon chewy here
tells me you're looking for passage to
the Alderaan system then there's then
there's a grandpa here or someone for he
doesn't give a [__] about anything but
you know the thing is is he's actually
kind of a teddy Bearer because he gave
key a big hug because of everything
everywhere all at once a short round is
you're gonna teach me how to do this
it's
you know here's the cool thing about all
the voice stuff that I've been given
over the years is that it you
necessarily have to learn how to use
your voice in different ways and so as a
on-camera actor I now know how to do
that job differently you know which is
fun